Quand je vois autour de moi les gens qui...
...Ah pardon
Quand je vois les gens autour de moi qui commencent à avoir des enfants
ou que je repense à mon père quand j'étais petit
Euh...Je me dis les papas ils sont quand même tous très différents
FAUX
Un vrai papa, par définition, ça a l'art et la manière de te foutre la honte
[Squeezie] : Bon papa comme d'habitude, hein ? Tu me déposes 30 mètres avant le collège
[Norman] : T'inquiètes fiston, j'ai eu ton âge, je sais ce que c'est
*Bruit de dérapage*
Allez file
[Squeezie] : Hello, ça va ou quoi ?
[Fille 1] : Salut ça va ?
[Garçon 1] : Ca va ?
[Squeezie] : Bien et toi ?
*Klaxon*
Tchao Titouan ! Bonne journée mon petit fiston !
Papa te fait un bisou en wifi !
*bisou*
Quand je pense que tu pissais au lit jusqu'à tes 12 ans
Aller Tchao !
Le beau gosse du collège !
*rires*
[Squeezie] : C'est un pote, hein, c'est pas mon père
J'ai plus le droit d'avoir un pote de 45 ans, ça y est
Moi, mon père et internet, euh... c'est vraiment pas l'amour fou, hein
On est pas sur une fusion, non
Mais il est mignon, la dernière fois il m'a souhaité Bon Anniversaire sur Facebook
Mais sur la photo d'un autre mec
Que je connais pas
Euh je sais même pas comment il a fait
Même Marc Zuckerberg il sait pas comment il a fait
Les papas ils font des vrais trucs de papas
hein, par exemple clipser leur portable à la ceinture
*Sonnerie de portable*
Ah !
Ah ! Appel manqué !
Bon bah, il rappellera !
*Téléphone se casse*
Les pères ils ont vraiment des demandes spécial papa
Zoé !
Tu peux me mettre la police en grand, je vois rien du tout
Non mais papa, c'est au maximum, là
Ah il est allumé
LOL
Un vrai père, tu vois, ça a un instinct, un vrai instinct de papa
notamment pour détecter certaines choses
[Norman] : Mattéo, tu fais quoi, là ?
[Squeezie] : Rien pourquoi ?
[Norman] : Range tout de suite cette cigarette dans le paquet de Camel Light que tu tiens dans la main gauche s'il te plait.
[Squeezie] : Euh...euh... OK
[Norman] : Tu sais très bien que c'est cancérigène. Papa aime pas que tu fumes ces saloperies !
Un vrai papa c'est important, parce que ça nous apprend des choses que personne d'autre pourrait nous apprendre, tu vois
[Norman] : Tu vois Xavier, les vrais trucs d'hommes, ça s'apprend pas hein, ça se refile de père en fils
Aujourd'hui je vais te montrer comment on fait pour réparer un moteur de voiture
[Squeezie] : Cool ! On commence par quoi ?
[Norman] : Eh bah tu commences par appeler un garagiste ! Hein, tout simplement
Et après je te montrerais comment on fait pour cuisiner comme papa
Des bonnes petites Margherita !
C'est vrai que le père, parfois il a un peu le rôle du parent autoritaire
En même temps, c'est vrai que dans l'éducation, c'est parfois important de mettre un petit coup de collier
[Norman] : Clémentine, maintenant tu fais tes devoirs !
[Clémentine] : Mais je comprends rien, vas-y aide moi !
[Norman] : Ok...
Alors...
BON, tu feras tes devoirs demain ! Mais demain tu les fais bien !
Ça commence à suffir là !
Parfois ton père, il a beau avoir 45 ans, tu sais pas pourquoi tout à coup
Il se croit à nouveau jeune
[Fille 2] : Comment je kiff son dernier clip, elle est trop ouf dedans
[Clémentine] : Grave
[Norman] : Salut les Jeunes, alors on Zone ?
J'espère que vous prenez pas de la gueudro
[Clémentine] : Papa, tu peux sortir de ma chambre s'il te plait ?
[Norman] : Aller, venez on fait juste une petite duckface pour mon SnoopyChat
[Clémentine] : Papaaaaaaaaa
[Norman] : Aller quoooiii, juste pour guolrire, on fait une Vine !
Ou alors, il essaie un peu de revivre sa jeunesse à travers toi
C'est vrai qu'il y a plein de pères qui veulent absolument que leur fils leur ressemble
[Squeezie] : Mais papa, t'avais dis qu'on irait voir les animaux au Zoo :
[Norman] : Ecoute Didier, on doit aller à Bricorama faire du bricolage, comme des hommes, OK ?
[Squeezie] : J'ai 8 ans, je m'en fous de bricoler !
[Norman] : On ne négocie pas Didier
Et rase moi cette barbe là, je l'aime pas trop, hein ?
Tu dis ça parce que t'es jaloux, c'est ça ? Toi y'a que la moustache qui pousse depuis que t'es né !
[Norman] : ALORS LÀ TU VAS TROP LOIN DIDIER, TU SERAS PRIVÉ DE DESSERT !
[Squeezie] : Mais Didier !
[Norman] : Il n'y a pas de Mais Didier, Didier !
Parfois, les papas, sous leurs airs de gentils pères de famille
Ils ressentent le besoin de nous prouver qu'ils sont quand même encore un peu rebelles
[Fille 2] : Mais papa le feu est orange !
[Norman] : Ah tu crois que ton père n'est pas capable de passer à l'orange ?
*Musique*
*Accélération*
*Frein*
Alors, on prend toujours son père pour une tapette ?
[Policier] : Bonjour, papiers du véhicule, s'il vous plait
[Norman] : Ne fais jamais ça
Les papas, en général, je dis bien en général
Ils savent faire la cuisine, mais ils savent faire un plat
C'est leur plat à eux
Ils te le remettent à toutes les occasions
Hop la ! La blanquette du dimanche !
La blanquette d'anniversaire !
La blanquette de Noël !
La blanquette du petit dej' !
J'ai tenté un steak frites
Mais là on est paaas euh sur un succès succès
Attends, les papas ils ont quand même une place primordiale
C'est quand même souvent à eux que revient le rôle de nous apprendre l'origine de la vie
*toc toc toc*
[Squeezie] : Entrez !
[Norman] : Tu sais, Nicolas, tu commences à être grand maintenant
Et en tant que père, c'est mon rôle de t'expliquer un petit peu bah comment on fait les bébés
Pour faire les bébés, c'est très simple, c'est papa cigogne qui va dans le nid de maman cigogne
Et là ils commencent un petit peu euh... bah à faire des bisous
[Squeezie] : Ah bon ?
Oh putain j'étais persuadé que ça se passait comme dans la catégorie gang bang sur X-Hamster
[Norman] : Ah ouais ? C'est aussi une autre façon de le faire ouais
D'ailleurs elles sont très très belles ces cigognes
Ecoute c'est n'importe quoi ! Je te confisque ton ordinateur !
Et je te confisque ton chargeur aussi !
Et c'est quoi ton mot de passe ?
[Squeezie] : C'est "Je suis H o m o"
[Norman] : Je suis H.O.M.O, ok
[Norman] : Je suis quoi ?
[Squeezie] : Je suis homo
Mon père, quand il me parle de son enfance, dans le milieu ouvrier du nord de la France,
J'ai l'impression d'avoir eu une vie de prince comparé à lui
Tu sais je culpabilise de ouf
*Musique triste* [Norman] : Tu sais Enzo, quand j'avais ton âge, à la maison on se lavait avec de l'eau glacée
On avait une pomme de terre pour tenir tout l'hiver et...
Nos jouets c'était simplement les... les phalanges de nos amis morts à la guerre
[Squeezie] : J'ai vraiment une enfance facile à côté de toi papa
[Grand père] : Mais t'es qu'un sale mytho !
T'as eu une enfance carrément cool !
[Norman] : Ca va j'ai le droit de romancer un peu ma vie quoi !
C'est bon !
[Squeezie] : Bien joué papi !
[Grand père] : Mais quel c** !
*Musique triste* Par contre moi, quand j'avais 4 ans on m'a mis à la mine
Et en plus, on se faisait battre avec des fouets en feu
*fouet*
Bref, pour conclure
Ca va paraître évident mais
C'est jamais trop de le redire
Quand t'as la chance d'avoir un père présent à tes côtés
Bah faut en profiter, passer du temps avec lui
lui montrer que tu l'aimes, écouter attentivement ce qu'il a à t'apprendre parce que
Y'a des choses de la vie que tu pourras apprendre que par lui
[Père] : Je me souviens, c'était dans les années 87, dès qu'on jouait à l'époque j'adorais !
Je me souviens, j'avais les cheveux longs
[Norman] : Ah oui t'avais les cheveux longs !
[Père] : J'avais rencontré maman depuis peu de temps et...
On s'adorait, c'était fantastique
On était fou amoureux
[Norman] : Ah ouais
[Père] : Et c'est comme ça que maman et moi on t'a conçu dans un camping...
...sur un matelas gonflable
[Norman] : Je vais faire un tour et réfléchir un peu à ma vie
[Père] : Abonnez-vous à la chaine de mon fils NormanFaitDesVidéos
Bon les vidéos c'est cool mais c'est quand même beaucoup mieux en vrai
Alors prenez vos place pour voir mon spectacle Norman Sur Scène que je joue bientôt
par exemple à Orléans, à Angers, à Marseille, à Nice et dans plein plein d'autres villes !
A très vite !